ok computer what's the big emergency why
wish you call me Mom sweetie I wish you
called me captain computer okay captain
sweetie let's get down to business we
are currently tracking multiple
developing crises that need urgent
attention first of all a massive
avalanche has been reported on the
planet Galactica second there's a runway
training system 7 it's headed for spike
Canyon she also sees a mayday signal
from the vessel Friendship Circle
they're under attack and uh oh this just
came in my sensors are reporting is
density of unknown origin has attached
itself to the Hall of this very ship
what are your orders sweet up captain we
have to defend the Friendship Circle oh
I just don't know who would attack those
poor defenseless cuties to the
teleporter room
I'm aboard the distressed vessel
Friendship Circle I found one of the
crew fake controls what a surprise oh I
wouldn't sit in those bean bag chairs
what happened here from an enemy vessel
or an alien creature or did you attack
yourselves in a fit of space madness yes
yes special nutrition taste for you
today tell your top flavor